[Music]
crypto uh cryptocurrency yeah no i don't
use crypto
um i may have made a buck here or there
off of crypto
i'm actually not really a big fan and
maybe i'm a little embarrassed that i've
invested in it uh because i think it's
wasteful i think uh it's using a lot of
earth's resources uh to do something
unnecessary and silly uh and so i'm
actually yeah pretty anti-crypto uh have
although i've personally benefited from
it financially you know i i'm constantly
have fomo about this and so much so that
we like parked uh four hundred dollars
into it and it's it's like half since i
parked it so you know um
my my opinion on crypto is kind of a
little bit uh a little bit negative
these days i mean i think that
the the other the shoe is going to drop
at some point that it's going to
experience a massive deflation i think
it has a great vision and i think it's
kind of going towards a really important
problem but i think the where we're sort
of at with it right now there's also a
lot of hype and a lot of um
yeah people who maybe don't understand
it yet and things that are sort of just
being done for the sake of being
attached to crypto and not necessarily
sort of actually getting at the heart of
the the real problem so i would say i've
mixed mixed feelings and uh i do not
currently sort of use it on a on a day
to day basis um
i'll say it's a waste of time and if you
really want blockchain just use git and
github
that's really going to get me murdered i
am glad that a lot of my friends have
made a lot of money that is that is that
is my opinion i would i would not bet on
being able to do the same thing it has
potential
and i have friends who are really
interested and invested in this topic so
i just
bought a little bit of crypto i don't
really play with it
i just bought it i just
you know i don't touch it so i'm like
okay like if this
gets even more pumped you know in the
future then at least i have some sort of
savings already there's a lot of uh
hypebro energy in that space and i think
that some of it's fun and some of it's
you know
not my favorite i don't personally have
any cryptocurrency
um i have a lot of questions around
you know web 3 and all of that but
i feel ambivalent
yeah i feel different
[Music]